this is my whole lot of woman our and in
honor of International Women's Day we're
checking in with some of the gifted
girls I've paired with successful women
who inspired them a few weeks ago I was
surprised a twelve-year-old fashionista
with baby fat founder Kimora Lee Simmons
check it out how did you get into
designing clothes oh when I was eight I
got my mom cleaning out my closet I was
like mom I don't want to give away my
clothes
I want to upcycle him so she was like
what's up cycling so I told her what it
was and she wrote me with in private
sewing lessons but I do have a surprise
for Skylar the woman behind baby fat and
so many other successful businesses
Kimora Lee Simmons come on
[Applause]
I brought you a little something here
and I we just wanted to tell you how
proud we are of you and if you would be
willing I would like to accept you under
my wing and offer you a mentor
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I didn't mean to do this but I invited
like two beautiful models to sit next to
you for an hour
yeah we couldn't go way back in the 90s
in New York I think I can tell you all
those women
welcome Morris so since the show have
you been able to like hang out with
Skylar or do anything with Skylar of
course yes so she came to New York we
brought her to New York and she came
into our studio or Atelier Casa de
Kimora that's family what's called it's
our baby fact I want you to call it that
it's not fancy and she we put her right
to work she had sketches we've lectured
we've mentored we've reviewed all her
things we've brought some things to life
she went ran all over the city she well
New York ad work houses yeah I would
walk into those places though and be
overwhelmed and y'all walk in and get
inspired I'd be like there's so much
fabric like I mean I did that like a
Joanne's just making quilts so a few
weeks ago Kimora offered to mentor an
extremely talented twelve-year-old
fashionista let's see what happened when
they met up in New York today is gonna
be a really big day because I was taking
my first step to being a real fashion
designer a little bit Tyler has a lot of
passion for design and as a
businesswoman and an entrepreneur and a
mother it's very important for me to
work to empower the dreams of young
designers and young women everywhere so
why don't you come into my office we can
chitchat about some things and I can see
what you brought me today I cannot wait
to talk about my fashion ideas with her
I'm really excited to show her my design
but I'm super excited to see what she
said about it oh here's all my designs
this one is just like an office or a
dress with the like a wraparound type
this one is like a balloon sleeve that a
come that's really cute I'm gonna have
to wear that this herd signs and her
sketches are exciting and vibrant and
fun and it shows a little bit of her
personality
this one is one access to sketch this
one last night I was a little bit
nervous to see what she had to say but
you'll have to have tough skin even when
they say that and they're not gonna use
your designs okay I see a lot of things
here I feel like we should work with I
definitely think we should take these
back to the design team and then we can
create some of these things out all the
sketches are really great but the red
stands out to me a lot because you can
dress it up or dress it down you can put
it with a blazer so we can absolutely
help her create that top and that pan
this is a team this is Cesar Megan and
Karen this is my little Skyler when I
walked in today I do not think that we
would actually be able to make an outfit
and I think it's gonna be amazing
so you mentioned this over that
whoa we're going we're going so this is
where it all starts before this I really
only just have me working on all of my
outfits so it starts with your sketch
and now that you've chosen a fabric
we'll create a pattern and then we'll
work it and check in with the
measurements things along the way and
then start assembly yeah like building a
house when you've been in the business
as long as I have you look more towards
creating a legacy so I think it when you
can look back and someone says you know
you helped me you helped me create you
hope to be designed you helped me
realize my vision that is how I measure
success the next time we see you this
will be done whoa
I definitely won't forget this day
because I think that one day I'll be a
big designer and see that this is where
it all like see a young woman like that
bold and that like just projected she
said I will be like she didn't say I
want to be she said I will be a peanut
designer and I'm like projecting that is
everything absolutely Wow so he KITT
what's that yet you have to so what's
the most important thing that you you
felt like you wanted to teach Schuyler
I wanted her to know first first of all
I wanted her to understand which she did
touch on rejection mm-hmm you may go
places I make it all the time except all
the time and all the magazines that
everybody write it they say I hate it or
they say I love it you have to be able
to like roll with the punches like she
said I'd have a thick skin so I wanted
her to understand that but beyond that I
want her to understand that the sky is a
limit that you can be a girl boss you
can be a girl woman designer you can be
who you are who we are and we can get it
done so there's no labels or titles or
boundaries that yes no limits back no
limits yeah so Kimora's he was able to
put together Skylar's design and she's
here to show it off come on out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
I'm just saying you had your arms behind
back every that might grow and you look
that good just walk with those arms
crowd I'm like so swaysway you look so
cute they hit everything oh the whole
look is nice was this exciting what was
your favorite carpet so I mean I Love
New York but my favorite part was
definitely getting to see like how the
team works and like if when she comes in
like the like her presence everybody's
just like oh let me like they're like
ready to help her and you could just
tell that everybody like loves working
with her that's amazing hey that doesn't
a a lot about people yes but I really I
really just wanted to thank you for
having like you have like a whole bunch
of jobs you have kids I'm just I just
want to thank you for like you know
having me
[Applause]
that's amazing
like would you either door back details
let's show that back you can look how
cute I can see you in that you're
already wearing like a red kind of
orange so come or you have one more
surprise for everyone though right yes
so when we when Skyler brought in her
designs she has like every good designer
has a sketchbook and I being me I'm like
I want that and we have to make that and
we have to do that so we did this outfit
for her yeah she created it sketched it
we assembled it manufactured if they'd
waited made it come to life and then I
have on another one of her designs from
her
[Applause]
as voluminous because the mom was
already a little luminous I took it down
I do a little point tuck at the top but
yeah this is her baby fat collaboration
is amazing you are you loving it did you
just love being in the building
everything just soaking it all in yeah
it was I've got I learned a lot that's
so cool that is so cool what a blessing
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going